barely a DOT perhaps to most of the
crowd but the new president's returned
to power too big a moment for them to
miss
[Applause]
they'd affectionately dubbed this
ceremony the lulapalooza and came in
their thousands to take part
is
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
ER to this process this is the third
time he's been elected but Brazil has
changed since his first two terms in
office over a decade ago
[Music]
I promise there wouldn't be a spirit of
Revenge but said anyone who made
mistakes will answer for them
[Music]
to Brazil
won with the narrowest
promised to end poverty and inequality
is
and to reverse the rate of deforestation
in the Amazon
so it's a big job for the transition
team isn't it and there are big gaps
your environment uh the agencies have
suffered big budget cards they've had a
lot of people leave
similar kind of thing happened in
education in health there's been some
damage and we need to get back to to
some of this capacity and some of these
policy commitments and and don't expect
it all to happen in the first hundred
days I think that's especially important
on the environmental issues
the new government is a broad Coalition
ranging from the left to the center
right
it comes after four years of je
bolsonaro the populist far-right former
president with a huge social media
following who has reportedly flown to
Florida after refusing to attend today's
ceremony
battles are lost he says in this
farewell social media post but we will
not lose the war
s have vowed to continue their movement
in his absence and in this deeply
divided country Sadia choudhary Sky News